breaking news were just saying that the
disgraced peer Lord Sewell has stepped
down from the House of Lords he's
written a letter says I have today
written to the clerk of the parliaments
terminating my membership off the House
of Lords at Jason Farrell who's there in
Westminster for us at this morning the
pressure just grew and grew it did there
were so many people calling for him to
resign and I think this letter really
was inevitable let me just read you a
little bit more of it
he says the question of whether my
behavior breached the code of conduct is
important but essentially technical the
bigger questions are whether my behavior
is compatible with membership of the
House of Lords and whether my continued
membership would damage undermine public
confidence in the House of Lords I
believe the answer to both of these
questions means that I can best serve
the House by leaving it he goes on to
say as a subordinate second chamber the
House of Lords is an effective vital but
undervalued part of our political system
I hope my decision will limit and help
repair the damage I have done to an
institution I hold dear finally I want
to apologize for the pain and
embarrassment I have caused and thereby
for the first time acknowledging this
story in the Sun in one of his
statements apologizing for the
embarrassment he is no doubt caused not
only to the House of Lords but to his
wife and family and it is interesting
that he mentions this point about it
being a technical question of whether he
breached the code of conduct that was a
big issue it was suggested by Baroness
Boothroyd that he had indeed breached
that code and Baroness de souza felt
that the code has seven principles and
it asks for you to act with intent
integrity and that was the aspect that
he was felt to have breached although
others Lord Brisbane who used to do his
job on the Standards Committee felt that
he had not actually committed an offense
against the House of Lords although he
described his actions as ghastly and I
think this issue has just obviously
repulsed many people
in the House of Lords felt that he had
to go wanted him to leave quietly even
though these new laws have come in that
allow them to ultimately expel him by
last night taking a leave of absence and
saying he would potentially come back
into the House of Lords that just caused
more consternation because people really
felt this was going to drag drag on and
on and on they would come back after
recess whether the police investigation
had found anything or not then they
would have to have this inquiry and it
could have continued tarnished the name
of the House of Lords so I think he
feels that this is this is his way of
dealing with it and he's answering the
calls of many and handing in his
resignation or the image